[Applause]
i've always loved teachers but with all
the additional challenges they're facing
right now
i can say without a doubt they are real
life superheroes and i mean capes and
all
and in honor of national teacher day i
get the pleasure of talking to an
amazing special education teacher
from the bronx everybody let's say hello
to jamel
holmes
thank you thank you okay you're from
east
bronx academy for the future correct all
right will you
talk about this school sure um i'm a
sixth grade teacher
and you know i get really excited about
talking about east bronx academy
specifically because i was a student
there and graduated in 2008
and i came back 10 years later in 2018
to become a special education teacher
there
you go above and beyond for your
students will you please tell us about
that
sure so i've done tons and tons of
things for my students but one of the
things that i really really love to talk
about
is the trip that we do to the barber
shop because
this really sets the tone and teaches
our children outside of the classroom
ways in which to be presentable having a
male role model
and also offer mentorship so every
year we go to the barber shop and my
barbie
does free haircuts for us and the
students are so so excited
and they're like am i really getting a
haircut today like i'm at the barber
shop with my teacher
have you ever read the book crown by
derek barnes
no i haven't oh my god it's so beautiful
it's this children's book
and it's about this boy going to a
barber shop and it's
poetic and artistic and beautifully
illustrated
by gordon james and they're actually
friends of the show so i'm going to get
you and your students this book because
it really speaks to that moment what do
you think the goal
of a teacher should be so specifically
my goal as a teacher is to really build
these relationships with students
beyond the classroom i really just want
to be
that role model that the students have
they can come to me
and have these conversations about
whatever's happened in their lives
many of our students come from unstable
houses and one parent single-parent
houses and things like that
so i want to be that person that they
can kind of go to beyond the school
there was a moment where my daughter
olive was missing a school assignment
online and we were scrambling
and she was actually going to her dad's
for the weekend
and we were just it was the height of
corona you know
the pandemic and we were trying to
figure out the transitions and we always
talk about you know how transitions are
hard
and i was like oh god and you're late
for your online class and i just
put my head in my head and i said you
know what olive right now
i want to talk about there's school
smart and there's life smart
and we're working on life smart so the
lesson can wait
because i know this school you're going
to be school smart
but right now we're working on life
smart we talk about school and it's so
big and global
and we're trying to reform education
right now but school supplies is
something that really speaks to you
yes definitely school supplies so a
specific experience is throughout the
pandemic
i was able to purchase food
school supplies everything my students
need so i went out
and i drove up to students houses and
they came downstairs and
and students kind of got those things
that they need and those are kind of the
relationships that i love to have
with my students well we have a special
delivery actually mr postman jim
are you here special delivery for
jamelle it's a big bag
um there is an amazing company called
school specialty
and they wanted to donate to you this
entire bag is filled with school
supplies
thank you so much i cannot wait to share
this with my students
we are just so in awe of everything you
do
and your students are as well in fact
jim
i believe there's another special
delivery perfect
she'll deliver some mail thank you jim
so much thank you jamal you actually
have a little homework tonight yourself
these are letters that your students
have written to you
thank you wow and i'm sure that
everybody just wants to sky right and
shout off the rooftops
that everything you're doing is what we
need to know about
and shine a light on and you're just so
awesome and thank you
you're the living example of what is
possible from and from a teacher
and it's more than what's in the
classroom i believe that with all my
heart i didn't even go to school
and i love life smart but i'm so
passionate about education and my girls
i want them to be in school for the next
50 years
but it is about real life as well as
what happens in that classroom
and you are just straddling that line
with such grace and beauty and i
am in awe of you and i thank you so much
for coming on this show thank you so
much phil
i love to be here and i wouldn't be
anywhere else today
than right here talking about the
amazing work that's happened in the
bronx
and the stuff that i'm doing my students
well we also just have to say before we
go to commercial that you are giving a
head
to toe look jamal really thank you
you are bringing it you're amazing
[Music]
you